muy raros así calificaron desde la
agencia europea de medicamentos los
coágulos sanguíneos que presuntamente
podría causar la vacuna de astrazéneca
el próximo jueves comunicarán los
resultados de la investigación pero
siguen recomendando su inoculación
seguimos firmemente convencidos de que
los beneficios de la vacuna de
astrazéneca para prevenir el kobe 19 con
el riesgo que éste tiene de
hospitalización y muerte superan los
riesgos de los posibles efectos
secundarios el lunes alemania francia
italia y españa- a las principales
economías europeas suspendieron
temporalmente la vacunación con
astrazéneca por sospechas de trombos
entre los efectos secundarios sin
embargo después de las informaciones de
que los coágulos no son superiores en
los vacunados que en la población en
general en francia confían en reanudar
pronto la vacunación espero
fervientemente que podamos reanudar la
campaña de vacunación con la solución de
astrazéneca lo antes posible esta
técnica además de las principales
economías alrededor de una decena de
países europeos cancelaron la vacunación
de astrazéneca algo que no han hecho en
países como bélgica
donde done un disco con los datos que
disponemos no podemos decir que existía
un riesgo adicional asociado a la vacuna
de astrazéneca en cuanto a los trombos
de bus sin embargo las dudas en torno a
astrazéneca ya están en el debate
público como para estos policías
españoles ya vacunados no sabemos cómo
va a evolucionar esto y además tenemos
la incertidumbre de qué es lo que va a
suceder con la segunda dosis una
incertidumbre que alimenta las
especulaciones sobre a qué se deben
estas suspensiones tras meses de
disputas entre astrazéneca reino unido y
la unión europea por la escasez de dosis